si tu étais un vice la ligue
oui oui c'était le pire vivent tout ce à
quoi la rue lâche c'est les gens quand
on l'a quand on leur fait le portrait
chinois on leur dit c'était une pleurs
lors il serait comme quitter la non
mixité t18 de l'autre et là je serai là
c'était une guerre jusqu'à laquelle
aubin la dernière parce qu'elle était la
plus terrible où alors
iran irak parce que c'était vraiment
eric mais la dernière guerre traiter
tant à l'aller à lyon où elle était pas
mal de réussite
c'était collaborateurs tu serais
christelle et ne fait pas un grand nom
mais c'est un jeu c'était un grand
collaborateur tu serais qui maurice
taxes je suis pas mal c'était un
supplice
oa supplice comment appelle-t-on ces
supplices où on écarte ça s'appelle de
laisser pas l'écarter parce que les
cartes et autres shows et gagner
s'ajoutent câble car tellement les
cartels ces l'écartèlement peut-être je
suis ici qu'est né l'insee mais si tu
étais un accident le pire des jeux
étaient dans l'avion parce que je prends
souvent l'avion et comment ses traits à
la base est très à la mode en angleterre
se trouve que ces médias mais il faut
pas prendre la journée